before we begin i'd like to give a huge
thank you to audible for supporting the
h3 podcast if you want a 30 day free
trial go to audible.com forward slash h3
podcast and get yourself some bomb slam
and free entertainment on us help
support the show go to audible.com
forward slash hb
with that said let's get slamming
welcome back to another episode of the
h3 podcast sitting here with your boy
idibs
he is a very popular youtuber who has
exploded by exposing the [ __ ] frauds
on youtube
that's a little bit much he's known as
the great exposer he's known
as he unboxes things
he and he's got a new series on youtube
called comedians on razors eating
crunchwrap supremes
i think they'll probably be a new
episode out you guys should check out
yeah just yeah
it the name changes it's not always it
we're it's comedians that's all you call
it yes but dot dot fill in the blanks
well the one we did was comedians on
raisers eating crunchwrap supremes and
you're planning your second episodes
with vsauce yeah hopefully that goes up
by the time we put this it would i would
like less time let's find that up
pollination well ian is a very funny guy
his channel is idubbbz tv the tv may let
you know that he's a little more serious
than the average youtuber yeah buddy
broadcast broadcaster yeah but if you
don't know his channel definitely go
check it out he's one of the he's one of
the funniest guys he's just he's killing
that's really kind of useful he's a
sweet [ __ ] guy and i never like him a
lot
you can't say it yourself but you
hopefully that you have friends around
that will just say it for you and then
you're like thanks doug
you know what i mean i appreciate i
really appreciate my uh tv director
friend ethan klein yeah telling me when
my shit's good yeah i got your backpack
so um
my first question for you mm-hmm is uh
do you remember there was this one
youtuber who's really big do you
remember leafy is here
is that the guy who looks like a lesbian
no no no that's a different one this guy
looks like a [ __ ]
oh
now i'm going now i feel like i'm going
in
no he's like a little he's got like a
little chin i guess is what he's known
for the lesbian's the other guy oh yeah
no i haven't heard of him i don't
remember him i remember him vaguely
this feels mean yeah this feels good
this feeling i think's planned for this
to be funnier
let's just wrap it up
call it a day you'll just wrap it
so
ian is known for like
you've known for your very kind of
inflammatory like
you you you're not you're very anti-pc i
would i would describe you as the the
i'm gay thing i mean that i'm proud of
that yeah so i'm definitely proud of
that well so ian has this thing was it a
collaboration with is it a filthy frank
or is it a maximal photo that would be
max mofo so he goes so ian jumps into
the frame
in a batman-esque fashion and he just
says i'm gay
how'd i do yeah
it's a little bit more i'm gay that's
better that's it more this one's a bit
effeminate yeah i needed sorry i wasn't
you're i need to build my confidence
levels yeah yeah to proclaim that yeah
so that the little meme
is now what you're you're that i'm gay
guy yeah
i don't mind that it's funny yeah it's
funny i really like it it's it's cool
are you gay
no
i have a lovely girlfriend who's in the
room right now
was he gay i mean you would know better
than anybody
he's a little gay
yeah that's it i've i've had
relationships like that almost where
you're like i'm not gay but i have a
friend who i [ __ ]
yeah right that's what you're saying
when did you have that
i think it came out weird and it
wouldn't hurt that's kind of a little
weird but like one that
you know that no never mind it just
sounds bad you know that story you know
that i'm not first of all i've never
[ __ ] a guy
it just came out wrong but i was saying
say like sometimes you're like you have
that male friend you're like a little
too close with and people like oh
they're gay
that's you and max yeah definitely
except we're close yeah
well i'd actually say i'm more gay with
uh my my friend from high school raj
he's a good guy god bless you shout out
to raj big ups to ranjor reg you guys
[ __ ]
you love it yeah he wouldn't like that
like what what
what do you guys do together yeah not
gay stuff
what are you doing what are you gay
hillary so your i mean is your kind of
your style is very anti-pc is that by
intention or are you just expressing
yourself it is my intention i really
don't like being
[Music]
limited
i'm a big fan of freedom of speech
first amendment it's number one yeah
it's it's number one right up there with
the second amendment yeah i love you
guys do you have a gun on you
he's nodding yes but he won't say yes
no i would never bring a firearm to a
podcast
ian's [ __ ] packed and he's scaring
the [ __ ]
i'll shoot you and now he's going back
in the character
why are you just turn away
yeah what is that character
uh it's kind of like
i i like to think of it as a cholo but
like oh i didn't catch that yeah it's
it's sort of bad it's a bad character so
it's like it's inaccurate interesting
have you have you debuted that character
yet uh in private it's something you're
working on yeah okay and admittedly i'm
pretty sure i stole it from raj the guy
we mentioned earlier
oh yeah oh [ __ ] that guy he's gay it's
good to be a joke thief
however only be a joke thief
to people who aren't in the industry
because no one's going to complain there
you go that's wonderful have me get like
the funniest friends ever funniest
friends who are great comedians
stand up they're waiters don't ever
bring them in just have them come in be
funny and be like see you guys next week
and then you have all this material
taken and no one ever complains it's
brilliant i love it yeah
yeah craigslist get friends if you can
put a post on craigslist just get
friends
just put friends
that would be helpful to me
she's working on it now thank you
appreciate that
um old guy
in his 30s it's kind of kind of
intimidating in this podcast she's got
the beanie on she looks like she's she's
going to shoot someone no ela don't [ __ ]
around maybe it's the black shirt i
think the [ __ ] gangster is [ __ ] dude
she scares me we were talking about that
what last episode with bert kreischer
and he was talking about how he's
his wife is really like a strong bold
beautiful woman kind of character and i
was just saying like yeah ela scares the
[ __ ] out of me because we were talking
about like how we're both [ __ ] like
in a fight i feel like i can maybe beat
up
20 of all men
and then the 80 would just [ __ ] kick
my ass like kill me right and i'm not
talking like street fight i'm talking
like world war ii saving private right
one to one death match right you know
what i mean it still feels kind of good
to say like i can beat the [ __ ] out of
20
of guys well the thing yeah well
including it doesn't sound that good
though yeah it includes everybody yeah
and there's some people in wheelchairs
who will [ __ ] me up probably but my what
we were talking about was like even
though
i'm a weak ass man i could beat the [ __ ]
out of you no problem
but
but she would psychologically destroy me
you know you guys can put that to the
test probably be pretty good video
actually just a straight up blood bath
well it keeps coming up so it's almost
like at this point we just need to throw
down yola yo you better [ __ ] down i'm
gonna get into this cholo character yo
ela no look at me i'll have to exercise
no sounds like this holmes yup dog you
need to throw some dogs in no no dog
this guy doesn't say dog so
you need like he says you [ __ ] will you
[ __ ] you need a white laugh at me
white socks yeah and bring them up to my
kneecaps i actually do that i don't know
why
because you're a trollo eli used to make
fun of me a lot because i wear like big
white dead socks and you'll like pull it
up all the way
i'm sometimes not aware of that sort of
stuff i recall when i was younger in my
youth i'd wear the sort of button-up
t-shirts but i button it up all the way
to the top oh that's cholo as hell yeah
and i didn't realize i was just like i
don't like showing my neck skin yeah i
feel gay yeah so i buttoned it all the
way to the top and my friends were like
i think that you gang banging yeah
exactly and i was like
no i
i just i'm just homophobic dude yeah i
just don't want to show this area
i'm shy that's funny so in israel ethan
would wear his socks like that and no
one does that in israel look i'm just
being me
i used to get made fun of a lot because
where i came from
i'll just have you know i've held back
quite on set
sorry um when i was a kid
you know i would rock the high dad socks
they're comfortable they're cozy they're
white they roll them up and it's great
and then all of a sudden when i go to
israel people are [ __ ] goofing on me
like i was in the elevator with my boss
one time and he goes nice socks [ __ ]
he said that to me no they didn't well
no john said that to me in a nicer way
he didn't call me a [ __ ] but he's like
he he made me feel bad he belittled me
as a person for my for my taste in
fashion
you could use an upgrade
in a lot of ways
now i'm
yeah what do you think about that
yeah
the whole thing's just [ __ ] well you
[ __ ] wear sweatpants everywhere i
know i can get away with it i'm young
i'm like you're not that young i'm a
young guy i can wear dirt for youtube
you're old as [ __ ] dog you're old as me
dude that's why i like you yeah that's
that's we can relate yeah you're more
because everyone on youtube's so young
i'm 31 you're 27 right
37.
how old are you i'm 26.
[ __ ] yeah
i thought you were older yeah i don't
know if this is gonna work
come on quiz me dude
ask me about oh [ __ ] golden girls you
like gold girls i love gold girls what
was the name of tommy's oh i guess i'm
too old what was the last name of tommy
from rugrats the pickles yeah everybody
knows that yeah that's nice
but like so when you going back to the
pc thing
you just i mean like it's you just i
just really don't like i
always i envy comics who are able to get
away with saying [ __ ] anything yes
because like i don't really care
about
um
i i just think it's it's kind of it's in
a way it's kind of a skill it's like to
be able to frame your [ __ ] it's a
tightrope walk yeah and it's i feel like
it's more interesting
uh so i always just wanted to be able to
do it so kind of early on when i saw the
opportunity to say something i'd be like
all right if i happen to get bigger at
some point i can always point back and
say
this isn't offensive what i did then was
offensive that's funny so
get off my ass sort of thing
so you set the expectations that like
right exactly you already said that so
yeah this is not so so if president
obama tweets at you and he's like yo
idubbbz you're [ __ ] offensive
and then what do you point to and be
like yo obama chill out look at this
from my earlier career i mean
obviously the [ __ ] [ __ ] thing right
oh but that wasn't even that long ago no
it wasn't oh i mean has my career been
that i guess yeah by the way when did
you start youtube
okay so i started youtube i would say
around about five years ago
same time as us ideally
my my initial thought was hey i'ma be a
gamer i can play games and earn money
that's cool which is so funny because
you're like the gamer persona is one
that's so played out on youtube and
you're such a like counter culture
person that thinking back to you then is
is seems so different than who you are
now i was playing minecraft when i was
uh 20 years old damn you know
i it's it's
really embarrassing to look back at it
and say jesus not long ago
i was one i was one of these well to be
fair i don't think many youtubers can
look five years back and be like that's
i'm not embarrassed
right no it's true i think it's just
it's a it's part of the experience so
embarrassing yeah so it's i don't know
it's kind of cool to see
how quickly you can evolve and how how
things can change in a matter of a year
yeah i mean we're both pretty good
examples of that yeah on youtube it's a
week feels like a month yeah a year is
like yeah so you went from playing
minecraft and then what was the next
evolution uh
indie games i mean in general i played a
lot of indie games that's sort of where
i like kind of found a niche
uh i get a lot of a lot of people razz
me about that playing games like
overgrowth which is like uh i remember
that yeah it's it's a really cool game
they haven't gone anywhere with it just
because production's mega slow on an
indie game especially when you hire like
two people to work on it
um
but shots fired at uh overgrowth yeah
exactly shots fired it really all into
titles they all [ __ ] suck games suck
so once you were what what was the
transition from gaming to the next thing
you did uh okay so i i did sort of uh a
brief
news show sort of thing i wanted to show
my face in front of the camera so i i
called it gaming news crap and i would
just
talk about like
the the game the games that are
scheduled to come out or any random
thing like that wow
yeah those are privatized i believe
those will be released from
uh i don't believe they are now yeah
well you know that was on a separate
channel even because i had that channel
uh monetization disabled so
i we moved past that at this point
[ __ ] ews minecraft news gaming
updates i think people will kill for
that they would actually that'd be
entertaining yeah when the channel
starts plummeting i'll slowly release
those and it'll be like returning to
your roots yeah he's like oh this guy's
desperate
he's a natural at this
thing yeah so i i did that and then i
ended up having a segment at the end of
this gaming news crap thing called
kickstarter crap oh
and i would look at a random kickstarter
project and be like man this is pretty
shitty
um most of them are gaming focus still
though right so then eventually i
started just doing
uh kickstarter crap on its own
uh did a bunch of those videos i strayed
away from gaming
that's when max sort of like kind of
he left a comment on one of my videos
and
that is max moffo max mofo yes
and i did i had no idea who he was um
one of my friends just mentioned like oh
this dude's verified he's
right writing your comments
and then uh i was sort of trying to be
the cool guy when he tweeted me on
twitter i would like respond like
cool yeah
yeah dude one word replies and stuff
like
but you know he had millions of subs so
i was like yeah
it was a big deal it was a big deal yeah
yeah um
but like a year went by after that and
then we started talking more and then
kind of the rest is history i'd say so
the kickstarter crap actually looking
back a lot of those have a lot of views
now since your channel exploded that
series was so perfectly timed because
when you first started doing that
kickstarter was just such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show yeah there were so many people
trying to grab money with the most like
asinine dumb [ __ ] and i think the timing
of that of that series was wonderful it
worked out well yeah there were a lot of
other people were kind of doing a
similar thing red supra and um a few
others i think they uh they did the same
thing but um
i don't know it was all it was sort of
up for grabs at that time yeah it was
sort of a weird niche not too many
people were well it's like it's like a
gold mine yeah because it's like you're
always looking for that wonderful
perfect youtube video to like talk about
that's like so ripe for satire like the
one we did together about the curing my
color blindness but you go on
kickstarter back then and it's like oh
look
yeah i guess it's kind of like when we
started doing reaction to practice
it's a similar yeah it's a very similar
thing and you guys and and i i think
both feel the same way about
there's a lot of stuff to look at and
there's a lot of suggestions that fans
put out there and you really have to
weed them out because i recall getting a
lot of suggestions that were like
look at this kickstarter project
and i would look at it and be like well
this is clearly just a child that can't
do anything can't operate a web page so
like i mean i don't know what you're
expecting that's yeah you want me to
just go off on a tangent well like i
want a child out
well that one of my favorite emails that
we get all the time yeah is like hey
i've got a perfect reaction video for
you and then you click the link and it's
got like two views and it's like some
[ __ ] eight-year-old that they go to
high school with do they just want to
hear
something somehow in their mind they're
like ethan's gonna eat he's gonna
[ __ ] make a bit a whole video about
this guy and slam him i was thinking
that it might be fun at one point just
do it to do it just to surprise
everybody yeah
but this one kid who's just no he's just
like what the [ __ ] what is this like
that's actually yeah it could yeah i
feel like it could end up being a
positive thing if you frame it in the
right way so i got this email yeah you
start with the email what if well you
could actually flip it on the guy who
sent me the email
be like you know your video because a
lot of them a lot of them are very
they're
they'll they'll sign off on their email
xbluedragon49
yeah so you look good check out my
channel yeah check out my channel
my channel is much better than this gay
chat yo y'all [ __ ] heard of here
y'all better back off i deebs yeah he's
coming hard on all you [ __ ] haters
that's actually a brilliant idea
that's a wonderful story if you found
someone really worthy of getting blasted
i mean i don't want to give out too many
good ideas but yeah you can send out a
maybe a a message on twitter hey you
guys want anyone want someone for me to
roast
anyone at your high school email me
email me that's a [ __ ] 40-minute
roast video just calling you know
all these people yeah it's a youtube
brad's special yeah we'll have youtube
finally something good on youtube red
um [ __ ] youtube red
i
i have such a troubled relationship with
youtube i feel like i've spent so much
of my career bitching about youtube that
i almost like yeah i'm out of breath
dude just over it i'm out of breath i
like lost i feel like i just been beat
down you know i've been shamed i'm naked
in a dungeon they're like passing me
bread under the door i'm just like i
can't just just take me
i love youtube yeah youtube's all right
so we're gonna take a quick break guys
stay tuned it's gonna get juicy it's
gonna get fresh it's gonna stay spicy
stay
tuned once again i'd like to thank
audible for supporting our podcast
audible is an unmatched selection of
audiobooks original shows news comedy
and more i personally love using audible
when i'm playing overwatch or hitting
the gym losing that fupa but if you're
just goofing around and need something
to listen to audible is as good as it
gets the book that i've been reading is
alexander hamilton by ron chernow it's
the book that actually inspired the emmy
award-winning broadway play hamilton
it's a really fascinating book about one
of the most influential and
under-appreciated figure in american
history for our audience audible is
offering a free audio book with a 30-day
free trial if you want to listen to it
audible has it go to audible.com forward
slash h3 podcast and browse their
unmatched selection of audio content
download a title for free and start
listening it is that easy let's continue
on with idubbbz tv what would you say is
the worst thing on youtube right now
what is it that's going on there that
drives you crazy every time it's
interesting how quickly it changes
uh right now one of the things that
really grinds my gears
are these channels that have a very
specific
i mean you can almost identify them via
their thumbnails
um
332 dollar water versus one dollar
buzzfeed that's the buzzfeed yeah that
sort of stuff blown up yeah
it's crazy it's it's frustrating um what
do you hate about it
uh
you
there's there's almost nothing to the
video
a lot of the the personalities that are
in the videos they don't actually have
much of a personality
they are just there to
i don't know it's eye candy a lot of the
time you know the most sour drink in the
world
it's like it's very interesting of a
video yes i'm calling out wolf yeah that
was a great straight up call out the
wolfie no i mean i think he's a great
personality
that's a good example i think he's a
good personality there are other people
who
um
who they're sort of substituting
building their personality with just
more [ __ ] they're just gonna buy more
[ __ ] make
the biggest gummy thing you can imagine
uh phil
fill my bathtub with
tampons fill my bedroom with
i guess when you say that it's kind of
it's like a tex racks almost yeah but
like tech racks like i the guy's sweet i
like the guy but he has the p he has the
personality
i think i just had an aneurysm
he has the personality of like a paper
towel yeah and he's like guys i just
filled up this pool of coke it's crazy
i'm gonna fly a drone in it okay i flew
the drone in it wasn't that crazy thanks
for watching thanks for watching and
then it's like 50 million views your
your impersonation of it was so good
yeah thank you well it actually sounded
like uh was mine not good i feel like i
kind of don't you just reminded me nice
thank you it was so good yeah thank you
thank you
i like thank you you get
that the best part or the the easiest
way to uh impersonate someone or do an
impression is you just have like a very
specific phrase
and you don't bring it any further
what's up guys tech rex here
that's what you do you don't see
anything more if i see oh i want more
i want more yeah you have to watch the
extended version what's up guys
techsracks here yeah today
he's got like you have to lower your iq
like by 50 points and then you sound
like that correct yeah a little bit
what's up guys but like and then i have
to say to wolfie's credit
when i made a video goofy on him a
little bit about the like begging and he
immediately damned me and was like yo i
love your video it was only a matter of
time before someone called me out god
bless you and i was like that's a
classic i watched a lot of his videos
and i
it was
it was very funny like uh i i made fun
of uh the
the sort of the dick sucking face in all
of his thumbnails like looking at like
an object like right
because it makes for a good thumbnail
and i always knew that like
uh max like filming a little bit in the
slingshot one well that was the purpose
yeah that was the but it's almost like
two meta i feel like the people actually
click because i like the face oh but i
feel like you have to be inside to get
the joke yeah oh 100
yeah yeah yeah but i need some mouth
open uh
you do you do
um
i guarantee you'll actually get more
clicks i'm going to put that to actually
we should do it i guarantee you well
we're about to do a video together where
we make fun of this knife burning
sensation if it's if it's strokiers or
whatever happened yeah
so maybe we could do like a mouth of
gape
double
double thumb that might be a little too
much
you don't want to overdo it and he will
just [ __ ] yeah
edit out our mouths and put them
everywhere but to get back on track
wolfy in in one of his videos he just
drilled it every two seconds in the
video he was like
i would do dick sucking face
like in his normal video it was it was
hysterical
um and then i think pewdiepie had
mentioned something about him so he made
a whole another video about pewdiepie
and the whole thing was a riot so he
takes it really well he takes it well
that's all you can ask for yeah which i
appreciate i
well actually that cracks also did tech
rex took like a champ and we were even
like we even spoke about doing a collab
together yeah
he's a really nice guy yeah well at
first he's like who the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] which is fair enough yeah and
then i was like yo i don't remember how
we started talking about anyway he ended
up being a real sweet guy
shout out i loved him there's nothing
worse than making fun of someone and
then they take it so personally and then
they sue you for example that's the
worst that's a bit unfortunate when that
happens well that's the way i haven't
experienced that yeah it's i hope you
don't go through it you know hopefully
hopefully soon enough we'll talk more
about it it's just we can't really talk
the lawsuit by the way i know everyone's
waiting for updates on that it's still
well people are like oh well i guess the
lawsuit's gone no it's not gone it's
still here and it's [ __ ] crazy it's
it's getting we're about to go to
through deposition now like in
two days
it's stressful
but um i'm hoping we switched attorneys
so i'm hoping for to turn into relief on
that and hopefully wrap it up yeah it's
good that you're talking to people about
it or at least keeping people updated
because i know that a lot of people who
either you know
were following it or whatever you know
don't realize how
long of a process a lawsuit is and it
could be much longer
yeah it's not even really something that
you can like give
weekly updates about exactly like what
are you gonna do like what we've thought
about the whole thing started around
like april like look it's all yeah soon
it's gonna be a year already i've been
wanting to do an update video but it's
like there's almost nothing to say it's
moved so slow and now stuff's finally
starting to happen and it's out of your
hands it's bureaucracy and your
attorneys their attorneys a bunch of
lawyers [ __ ]
i mean look we
we fired our previous attorneys
i'll say more about that in the future
in the future when this is all behind us
but there's been some just [ __ ]
absolutely it's been a [ __ ] show
it's been a [ __ ] show all around man
it's been it's been one of the most
stressful things in our life
so when people react that way that sucks
yeah back to that
also when people take your dms and post
it to [ __ ] like deaf fame you suck
still can we talk about that
i gotta say whenever someone does that
like you're you're supposed to
you're so dead to me and probably to a
lot of people
who did it recently
i've seen some people do it recently
yeah
ricegum oh yeah
yeah when you're just like
beefing with someone you're like oh well
here's a dm where they said something
nice to me it's like [ __ ] off dog yeah
it's a little too much i
i'm guilty of showing dms i
when do you show them but i i
there are two occasions where i've
showed dms
the first one was with jinx
i
screenshotted me um
[Music]
asking him
if he if he wears a new bucket hat each
day
and it was just like a question mark
after it
so that's not too invasive it's not too
invasive but in hindsight i wouldn't
have done it it's not bad because you're
not like
having a conversation right when you're
actually having a conversation and then
someone just takes it and shows it and
it doesn't matter if you were even
looking back on good context like why do
you even do that yeah i don't know but
the bucket hat meme was okay i'll give
you a pass on that one what was the
other one uh the other one was uh
keemstar uh in the dms for the keemstar
video that was also
just too fast i gave you pass keemstar i
i tried to justify it in my head i was
like well he he shows people's dms yeah
and i've seen him tweet out dm's before
so i said hey if he's fine with it i'm
fine with it yeah what was it in
hindsight i wouldn't what was it he sent
you um
it was basically a threat with uh lol at
the end of it i'll ruin your career or
something like that that's like no i
feel like when someone threatens you to
that point and it's keemstar you you get
the warrant too yeah at the time he was
sort of like he had that mentality as
well
access exactly
yeah the axis of evil yeah so to speak
yeah well youtube has changed a lot in
the past it's [ __ ] three months it
goes up and down every two seconds well
i'm also like i after all that [ __ ] i'm
just like over the beef i mean we goof
on people
but like the way i handled the leafy
thing was
stupid
yeah was it was bad
but obviously it was all bad then
yeah it's weird
i don't know
i sort of like try to stay out of it
until it's like
you got your end sort of build up sort
of like emotionally build up and then
let it all out in a single video yeah
and then never mention it again until
it's on a podcast with
someone yeah tell me all about it
so what was it like leading up to the
leafy rant because he
and the leafy rant the leafy video
he [ __ ] stole he ruined rant by the
way can i just say that like being
making a rant used to be cool on youtube
and then every [ __ ] video he made was
the you know
brand number five yeah
yeah i really liked that
just the phrase rant because it it sort
of
exemplifies like a lot of what we all do
on youtube you know a lot of the times
it's just you know
it's really sort of like why you guys
use reaction it's like your reaction for
a video oftentimes i'll just get in
front of the camera and just say a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah
um
so yeah it's a bit disappointing but
yeah leading up to the leafy video i was
like
i don't know i was
i wanted to be smart about it
and i you know it was very much like the
keemstar thing it's like a lot of people
didn't realize because everyone decided
to jump on the bandwagon after the fact
but like leading up to it i was very
nervous because yeah obviously like it
was a big deal he he had many more
subscribers than me many people told me
like this is a bad idea [ __ ] tons of
people said i don't know if you should
do that yeah no well yeah i mean he made
my life [ __ ] hell when i tried to
well i did it so stupidly and badly
you're much smarter than me
but like um
yeah it was it must have been scary and
no one had really taken like major shots
at him since then and like
right we got pretty [ __ ] up from that
yeah it's the the whole thing was really
bizarre i was i was afraid like
at that point like keem's uh avid
supporters would you know
you know dox me or do whatever this or
that
sent in the swat team right but so so
that was the thing it's like the day
before i released the uh keemstar video
i called my local police and i was like
put me on the white list are you [ __ ]
serious i said give me a call if
anything happens they did the same thing
before the leafy one as well wow it is
that [ __ ] up though it is seriously
like some people are really just out of
their [ __ ] minds those of you
listening who don't like follow youtube
like it's that [ __ ] up yeah
yeah it's serious a lot of people don't
realize that series
or anything where ethan's words that's
[ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up dag
so um
yeah you were just waiting in line you
were collecting you were thinking about
it for a long time yeah because i i
above all i want to make the videos
entertaining yes like and that's that's
where i [ __ ] up
i think in my approach it was rushed it
was hurried
a lot of people want to do it i have
passion for me it's really like i want
to get the entertainment aspect of it
out there
um so the leafy one was the leafy and
the keemstar one
i really like there's previous ones that
i did like the fine bros if i had to
take any
content comp video back it would be the
fine bros one
because
for me i i felt like i was very much
jumping on the trend of like [ __ ] on
these two jews
and make fun of their [ __ ] faces yeah
and how much money they want yeah and
how greedy they are and that sort of
[ __ ] um
i mean i parodied that mentality in my
video
um so i i felt like i separated myself
but
i didn't feel like it was super
reflective of their content in general
and i take a pass on that
um
but the keemstar one and the leafy one i
felt good because
yeah it was fun to be creative it was
fun to do the gnome thing in the sewer
also i mean we can tell we were
we you
like you were in touch with us when you
were collecting information about those
videos i remember and you you worked on
them for a while yeah no you were you're
in there it was like yeah it's a project
it's an actual project well that's what
made him so good and i remember every
time you were kind of there you're like
the meme he was there when no one else
was kind of meme where you've got a face
in every panel you know because like
when i was hanging out with pewdiepie
and jacksepticeye markiplier and jontron
in new york when you dropped the
keemstar
video and that was when he was at his
most obnoxious like he was sitting on
the death star and he thought he was
like [ __ ] palpable
just dropping laser bombs calling
everyone pedophiles he was like [ __ ]
reign of terror yeah and you i mean and
it was like at the perfect time and you
dropped this 20-minute just
roast
of this gnome popcorn eating [ __ ]
right oh yeah and we all watched like
they had already washed at their hotel
room and i think we were busy all day so
we didn't have a chance they're like
they're like no i will watch this 20
minute long video again and we all
gather around john's house and we were
like we were watching we were clapping
it was like watching star wars it was a
great night you were genuinely you were
luke you were the luke skywalker
because it's like a it feels good
because it's like such a project
you know what i mean i like the idea of
having
[ __ ] you can churn out on like a daily
basis but like something like slow
building stuff is something in the
background that you work on slow cooking
yeah some slow cooking like sets that's
soft moist meat but keemstar has changed
so much since then well that's my point
too why your videos are so great is
because it has impact yeah i swear to
you that keemstar one and the leafy one
had such an impact i mean you [ __ ] you
you you destroyed him i feel like you
ushered us into the new age of like the
new age of peace doug you're luke
skywalker you [ __ ] took down the the
uh republic
god damn you think jesus is here yeah no
but for real regularly
no i yeah i agree
i mean and but at the same time you're
also just like in it for the memes yes
makes it even better you're not there to
like
i just it was really fun to do that
gnome stuff to be honest
it was i spent so much time in my room
painting up that gnome yes it obviously
didn't look like look that way at the
start i spent a whole night i didn't
know painting
and i was like so
i had such a good time i took so many
pictures of this gnome after it had the
g-fuel logo on it and i was like well
this will be the best video ever after
just doing that oh that's wonderful
well you definitely the thing uh ian if
you guys don't know he
you basically went from like 300 000
subscribers
to like now you have three million
in about a year
yeah in about a year
i didn't and i really didn't expect any
of it it was
each video that i put out i thought was
like the biggest like risk ever
you know i expected after the leafy one
like um
there's there's a good chunk of my leafy
uh my everyone's bouncing sort of
yeah the subscribers that are subscribed
to both of us yeah bounce out you know
what i found though when it's when i get
that feeling like this is a risky upload
like that's when you make your best
videos like i remember the last time i
really felt that was the
the cs go lotto one oh yeah when i
posted that i was like [ __ ] like because
i knew that was we were actually
scared yeah i was like are we making a
huge mistake doing this because this is
like there's actually money involved
this is a lot billions of dollars and
actual like legal yeah actual legal
ramifications yeah exactly
so when i that was like a huge like [ __ ]
yourself kind of moment that's crazy
that was that was i feel like you could
feel proud about a video like that
though because it does actually have
kind of an impact i i can say that's
definitely our most impactful video well
the thing was after we made that video
valve shut all of them down yep that was
like a five billion dollar industry
and it just all came crashing down
because these two [ __ ] numb schools
yeah pro syndicate and t martin and i
haven't told this story but this [ __ ]
freaks me out right after we posted that
video we went down to florida to meet dj
khaled and we went to uh universal in
florida this was like two days after we
dropped that video and i [ __ ] [ __ ]
you not when we were leaving universal
that night i saw t martin he was there
with his girlfriend and i saw him and he
was playing pokemon go because it had
just come out at the time and i was like
either that's [ __ ] t martin and i
didn't he's huge he's like a big guy and
i didn't know how you even recognized
him i was like no i was like i don't
know if that's him but then but then i i
looked on his twitter and he was at the
university that was him he was like i'm
at the universal i was like 10 feet away
from him right and i was like you know
we like
because i was like i can only beat up 20
percent okay and he definitely and he's
not in that 20 percent
no dude he might have a screw loose
that's what i'm worried about i mean
there's a good chance that he would have
been like hey nice to meet you but yeah
that was fresh that was fresh yeah it
was a week after that would have been an
awkward encounter i was not interested
in [ __ ] confronting him but isn't
that crazy yeah two days after we ran
into him and [ __ ] universal studios
that's interesting that that actually is
that reminds me of vidcon if you ever go
to go to vidcon
you're going to meet some familiar faces
i'm scared we've never been to any of
those you might want to
it's a humbling experience
what do you mean uh
well meeting the fine bros was a lovely
experience you know whatever what was
your impression on them yeah how was
that they're great dudes they're very
nice [ __ ] guys they're just getting
off wrong i
i don't feel bad for the video i made
but like
i think they're nice guys and i and i
appreciate that it's criticism and it's
it's it's i say it's deserved criticism
yeah well like we made fun of the way
they looked which is kind of whatever a
little bit [ __ ] low but it's fine
yeah well it's it feels weird because
you wouldn't feel bad about you know
making fun of
the way certain channels certain people
on channels look right but since they're
so like disconnected they're not [ __ ]
talkers and yeah they just [ __ ] up and
had like i feel like their intentions
maybe weren't malicious to begin with
and then the worst part that was their
little like spin video afterwards
yeah they're just not nice
i think they just have really bad pr
they're yeah they're not very
charismatic and they
i don't think they had
i guess good pr is a good way of putting
it i think yeah so
so you you ran into them how was that
yeah i got making a video about them
rafi
not benny benny wasn't there i don't
think rafi's the one who wears the
beanie all the time yeah
uh he was really nice i i sort of was
are you gonna be in an episode of
youtubers react anytime soon no i'm not
uh but i don't feel too bad about that
i'd love to see you react to some
[ __ ] gangnam style yeah um i i
approached him and i said hey man can i
get a pic
and you could tell you approached him
yes so you were doing a bit of a meme on
him yeah okay well i mean i wasn't doing
mean well you know you're like hey i
[ __ ] roasted your ass can i get a
picture with you yes it's a bit of a
meme but but you could tell he was
hesitant so i said i'm not posting it
anywhere or i'm not posting with the
caption is what i said uh it's just me
picture with the legend rafi yeah so i
just took a picture
it was friendly enough interaction and
he said
i was like listen man
no hard feelings
it was just a little trend yeah yeah or
something like that well that's a good
way to put it yeah
and he was like
well i think it would be really nice to
have a dialogue or a discussion about or
something like that it's a very friendly
way of putting it
and um
and later later during the event me and
max and a few others like were all in a
group setting and we talked about
youtube reddit and a few other things so
the whole thing was a very positive
experience and i'm glad i
it
and the reason i
before i said it was humbling and it
really was it was like i felt very
uncomfortable because i had made this
video about him i was like i'm deserving
it's one of the reasons that i kind of
dislike some of the commentary channels
out there is when they go in really hard
i'm like
you need to interact with these people
that you make fun of in real life just
to be reminded
of what you're actually doing kind of
thing right yeah uh so interacting with
rafi when you see his face and you're
like and then you're just a real
and you're like [ __ ] like exactly yeah
this is real life he felt this [ __ ] yeah
i the the
the internet wall is no longer there i'm
five feet away from him yeah it becomes
real that's an interesting that's like
also it happens when your channel
becomes big because then most of the
times the videos you make they're
definitely going to see right like when
you're a small channel exactly you don't
know who's going to watch your videos i
was much more loose with my lips on
twitter and everywhere else when i was
smaller yeah and now i have to kind of
if i say like when i was smaller i would
have without a heartbeat said some mean
[ __ ] about pewdiepie right but now
i would be like he's my friend he's my
friend
i like him he's wonderful swede he's a
swede
well
he's a swede um no i 100 relate to that
too i mean there was a point when we
started making our reaction videos when
we were like we would actually ask
ourselves i wonder if they are going to
see this like we'd make a video about
vitale or dj khaled or whoever the [ __ ]
we're making fun of prank invasion we're
like wow i wonder if there's if they see
this i wonder what they'd think about it
but then you get to the point where
you're like i'm sure they saw this and i
hope they don't sue me
oh that's not in everyone's head
incorporate incorporate fast incorporate
not that that's gonna save you from
anything corporate
uh youtube's crazy
yeah it is so you think that going to
vidcon was an overall positive it was a
very positive experience i think um
did you meet a lot of fans uh not that
many fans um i mean there was a fair
group of people the the more
youtubers or celebrities or whatever
that are in close proximity to each
other the more people are like it's okay
to approach them sort of thing whereas
like if someone passes by it's just that
one person is like i'm not sure
you guys as a pair ethan and eli it's
like that's definitely them mm-hmm and
i'm i got you yeah well i think that's a
good point yeah maybe that's actually a
good point when they see ila next to me
it's a confirmation then they're like oh
boom got him got him i get approached
more when i'm with uh the boys
yeah george the gang exactly
when you're with the the whole gang how
do basics there with you guys
uh does he just like financial
information not typically um
no not typically he like but he just
like kind of s
satellites out of there that's all
confidence confidential
[Music]
there's some theories that's one of many
things i heard there's a theory that i'm
how to basically yeah i saw that i wish
i wish i was yeah it's sort of like that
anonymous thing
we're all how to basic yeah no i'm not i
confirm i'm not but i wish i was yeah
[ __ ] i love that guy yeah
um
what's it like working with with max and
and george and how do basic
i love them all because you fly out to
australia you go out there for like a
month
and you work with well yeah a little
less than a month but yeah couple weeks
feels like a month and you work with
these insane yes uh filthy frank max
mofo and how do basic which are like the
three nuttiest channels on youtube yeah
and and one and i think your big your
big
exposure before the leafy and keemstar
thing was from working with these guys
correct where your channel just went
crazy
um so yeah what's it like what's it like
oh it's awesome uh they're all
very different uh
how too basic is like the funniest
person on the planet
he's gotta
i want more from him yeah sorry well the
fact that he can just like he's been
doing this for like five years where he
just breaks eggs on [ __ ] and even
somehow he's managed to keep that fresh
and entertaining yeah that is just a
testament to his genius yeah he's a
genius it's insane he's a bit lazy
though he should upload a lot more get
on your [ __ ] howdy basically
i think yeah right now it's been i think
like two weeks since he's uploaded
something well his shit's hard to make
it's not good
it's like [ __ ] it's not hard no
what about cleaning up afterwards i mean
yeah it takes a little while to clean up
but like
if you guys don't know what he has that
[ __ ] cleaned up in a day it's not a big
deal yeah his videos are short though so
it kind of sucks on youtube it's very
similar to animations he works hard yeah
he makes a huge mess he spends a lot of
money and he doesn't get paid very well
because his videos are short that's how
youtube works correct longer videos you
get paid more
yeah
yeah um and then max i'll like like we
said earlier i'll always have a soft
spot in my heart for max max he was
watching my videos before anyone else
was when i had like
20k subscribers he's watching my videos
that's really cool um he can he
he
it's so funny
it's so funny to see actual like
i'll post memes that only people will
understand if they
if they had watched like a really old
kickstarter crap
and max knows all those he can he can
quote my videos word for word
and these people who are like i've been
a fan since 100 subs they don't [ __ ]
know the [ __ ]
that's so he's actually number one i i
deep's favorite oh yeah max is a
legendary i love max also he's so up to
date with like he knows everything
everything this guy is
i swear to god if i wanted to like if
there was a youtube trivia game show he
would be on my team
on this podcast for a youtube trivia tv
yeah yeah trivia no like this guy's a
wealth of knowledge like if i ever have
a question about obscure youtuber like
who is this and what's going on here i
shoot him at dm and he's like
yeah after after like 30 seconds you see
the the blue dots show up and it's like
a wikipedia article yeah i'm like thanks
doug yeah yeah oh like whenever there's
an interesting conversation on twitter
max is always involved
with some snide [ __ ]
yeah but yeah max is great and of course
we don't even need to say it george's
george he's just a [ __ ] clown i
[ __ ] hate george i think he sucks
yeah the filthy frank we're talking
about he's a real monster and he has a
big drug problem yeah people don't talk
about that but he's on drugs a lot in
math people are going to believe that he
does meth a lot it's a bad thing well
they should believe it because it's true
he smokes a lot of meth he passed me the
cr he brings me meth every time when
we're at our house and i'm like dog i
don't i'm i'm like i'm married i have
work like yeah i can't he was just he
was just whittling on an apple said i'm
gonna make a pipe out of this dude and
that's actually real why
like why we're just hanging out like
grab a grab a beer or water dude chill
have a water dog how about apple cider
yeah no i'm kidding that's great
actually i was gonna say we have the
same story with george he was the first
that's true who found our channel
well not the first by like the really
big youtuber who found our channel and
he was watching our stuff from like so
long ago like all the
old embarrassing videos he was watching
that's really cool it's so cool the
embarrassing stuff is the best
he one of our biggest breaks was when we
we probably were so small and george had
like this he was like a [ __ ] god to
us back then like filthy frank and he
had a huge facebook page
and he posted we made this video ainsley
harriet exe which is like what we see
these video edits and he never does it
but he posted that video on his facebook
page yeah and i think we got like you
know
500 subscribers that day or something
that was like our biggest day ever we
had like our sub page open we were
refreshing oh wow we're like whoa that's
so fun
and he left a comment on one of our old
videos it was like a get wrecked like
one of our dance videos and he's like
man you guys he said something really
nice and i'm like and people like clap
clap club and in my mind i'm like yeah
[ __ ] of course i want to collab and
so i was like yeah you want to do it and
he's like
yeah
eventually when we actually moved i
think we ended up talking on twitter dmv
or something but
he he was there he was there when no one
else was
yeah like george is is one of the
sweetest [ __ ] most genuine guys yeah
and he he's a huge boon tour to helping
us and i'd suck his dick i have and i
would again yeah i love that [ __ ] when
it's so genuine when you're like at a
basically a low sub count and like
they they ca if they if they can quote
one of your videos it's pretty good it's
so that's like yeah that's the best
when they're doing it in public though
but it's pretty cool
george does that in public no max max
will occasionally like try to embarrass
me but yeah
hey
that's pretty good
you're really [ __ ] loud i'm like shut
up
hey he created you dude yeah pretty much
that's his attitude he's like [ __ ] this
guy i'm like
yeah
who else was it there was one other
people snipers snipers
and jontron and jontron yeah john
john and george were our [ __ ]
that's really nice yeah yeah god bless
them it's so important coming up i feel
like no youtuber can make it to like a
high level without some some help right
for the most part unless you're like
ricegum or wolfie or leafy who just like
all of a sudden youtube's like i choose
you
you know and like the invisible youtube
hand just propels you to the top like i
feel like you need some help
yeah absolutely and those were our guys
yeah and your guys were you had the same
guy [ __ ] george is a saint george max
and
yeah
how to he's not a saint yeah
anyway let's take a quick break two i
got like two subs for being featured in
how to basic video really too yeah how'd
you track this
i mean
it could have been less subs actually it
could have been long
all right well
well it was great being on the h3
podcast it's fun thank you for watching
remember to subscribe on itunes and uh
google play music leave a review
uh appreciate you for doing that that
helps us a lot thanks subscribe to
idubbbztv subscribe yeah idubbbztv2 yeah
and idubbbz okay now you're asking too
much don't push don't be too pushy
twitter you only get two channels
i dubs games the last time you upload on
that [ __ ] thing more minecraft let's
plays coming up yeah anyway thank you
guys for watching we love you we
appreciate you we will be seeing you the
next time god bless god bless
god bless
[Music]
you